un pequeño museo al sureste de Londres
comenzó el proceso oficial de devolución
de elementos saqueados a Nigeria se
trata de los bronces de benín uno de los
artículos más preciados para el país
africano arrebatado por la corona
británica la devolución es la respuesta
a la petición de la Comisión Nacional de
museos y monumentos de Nigeria la acción
es recibida como un gesto de moral
apropiada para las autoridades
nigerianas
creo que si la mayoría de museos ahora
están involucrados en la repatriación de
los objetos saqueados porque los otros
museos están simplemente observando
sentados allá afuera si ven que esto
está sucediendo en la mayoría de museos
importantes de todo el mundo Entonces
todos los demás deberían devolver los
objetos saqueados según los registros
los artefactos fueron incautados en 1897
durante una incursión militar británica
junto con otros miles de artículos y
terminaron en museos de Europa y Estados
Unidos El acuerdo entre ambas partes
asegura que seis de los artefactos serán
repatriados en Nigeria mientras 66 de
ellos permanecerán en calidad de
préstamo en el Museo de orliman en
Londres el consenso abrumador fue que
los objetos habían sido saqueados y como
tales deben ser devueltos sobre la base
de que fueron adquiridos por la fuerza y
bajo coacción las autoridades nigerianas
esperan que estas devoluciones aumenten
la presión sobre el museo británico de
Londres el cual posee por mucho la
colección más grande y significativa de
bronces de benigno